hello and welcome to the introductory
video of the AWS developer associate
level course offered by simply learn in
this video you will get to know some
interesting facts about AWS get a brief
overview about the course and understand
how the certification can help your
career Amazon Web Services provides a
highly reliable scalable low-cost
infrastructure platform in the cloud
that powers hundreds of thousands of
businesses in 190 countries around the
world
the worldwide cloud computing market
grew 28% in revenues in 2015 which is
110 billion US dollars and the public
cloud revenue is expected to grow to 167
billion dollars by 2020 in a recent
survey conducted by cloud management
company right scale to assess the
challenges regarding cloud computing 32
percent of the respondents cited lack of
resources or expertise as the number one
challenge against 29% citing security as
the biggest challenge the AWS
certification holder takes home an
average salary of 125,000 $871 which is
an increase from 114 thousand nine
hundred thirty-five dollars last year
AWS developer associate is the perfect
certification that proves your technical
expertise in identifying appropriate AWS
architecture and in designing developing
and deploying optimum AWS cloud
solutions you'll enhance your existing
knowledge of AWS so you can identify and
deploy secure procedures for optimal
cloud deployment and maintenance you
will learn how to develop and maintain
applications written for s3 DynamoDB sqs
SNS SWS AWS elastic Beanstalk and AWS
cloud formation you will be able to
identify and implement cloud security
best practices with the certification
you will be an asset to any organization
helping it to leverage the benefits of
best practices around
advanced cloud-based solutions and
identify and implement the appropriate
architecture for development testing and
staging environments simply learns AWS
developer associate level course will
help you understand the key concepts
required to prepare for the
certification exam before diving into
the course details let us get a glimpse
of all the interesting ways you get to
learn about AWS delve into the various
AWS services work with AWS management
console learn the CLI commands validate
your knowledge the practice assignments
and the three live projects are included
for you to gain hands-on experience with
AWS management console and the CLI to
become a domain expert in building
deploying and managing systems in AWS
this course comprises 24 hours of
instructor led training 15 hours of
e-learning and 3 hours of demonstrations
to understand technical details
associated with data management
networking security and more you will
also be provided with three question
sets totaling 180 questions to validate
the depth of your knowledge what are the
prerequisites for this course you should
have attended AWS essentials course or
should have equivalent experience you
should have knowledge developing
applications with API interfaces you
should have a basic understanding of
relational and non-relational databases
and be familiar with messaging and
queuing services you can reach out to
the teaching assistants support staff at
any time during the course for
clarifying your questions and for
assistance with projects you can submit
your queries at help and support on our
website or get connected with our staff
using simply talk and live chat options
this concludes the course introduction
and we hope you are all geared up to
begin the AWS certified developer
associate level course let's get started
with the first lesson AWS overview happy
learning
you